[音楽]
なんだよ急に呼び出して
忙しいんだよ
最近のYouTube見てるからなんだよ
そんなガッツリ見てるわけじゃないけど
どのYouTuberさんが何かあったか
なとかそういう情報程度には
見てるよ
HIKAKINさん20億円のお家に住み
だし
そうらしいな
ヒカキンさん
すごいよな20億円かさらに
チャンネル登録者1000万人突破する
ねすごいな
俺も苦労したんだけどな1000万人行く
のに
なんだよ
[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですはい皆
さん最近YouTubeですごい話題に
なってることがたくさんありますねええ
あのね結構いろんな視聴者さんから連絡来
ますどう思ってますかとかこれに関して
どうですかとか
[音楽]
知らん知らんよ知らんって言いたいところ
なんですけれども知らんじゃ済まされない
ポジションみたいな感じなのでちょっとね
これだけいろんな人が気になってるんだっ
たらどう思ってるのかを話したいと思い
ますもうほんとそれだけそれだけですもう
本当にそれを聞いて何を思ったかどう思っ
てどういう気持ちなのかもうほんとマジで
普通に素直に話したいと思います今日それ
だけそれだけだけど気になるでしょもう
この2大ニュースもう両方なんか俺に関係
あるというか俺も視聴者さんだったらこれ
始めどう思ってるんだろうって思うような
トピックがでっかいニュース2つあったの
でちょっとね両方取り上げて話していき
たいと思いますまずトピックスその1私の
大先輩HIKAKINさん親分が20億円
のうちに住み始めました
おめでとうございます
それを受けて4億円のおうちに住んでいる
はじめ社長どう思ったかっていうのは
ちょっとまあ話していこうと思うよあのね
すごいまずはすごいしか出てこない20億
って
いうちょっと
放心状態みたいにはなりましたただねあの
ここだけの話をすると親分にちょっと相談
を受けててたまにねそういうお家の話とか
結構してたんですよ撮影の合間とか家とか
賃貸とかのお話たまにしてたのでそんなに
驚きはしませんでしたただ20億
[音楽]
行ったなって
素直にポカーンて言ったなって思いました
ねいや20億って4億円の家がかすむ
そうそういう意味で多分注目されてるんだ
よね
比較されちゃうと思うのよ20億円の
HIKAKIN4億円のはじめこの5倍の
差
[音楽]
どこだ東京東京でしょ
行かせてください行かせてくださいでも
あるんですけどもそうね4件と比べて
20億やべえなってもう純粋に思いました
という気持ちが純粋に強かったんですけど
もう1個だけ違いがあるとしたら俺この家
3億円って買ってるんですよ購入もう家主
が自分もうこの家の中何をどこぶっ壊せ
何しようか全部自分の自由なので俺は
購入で親分は賃貸家をお借りして住んで
るっていうのでそこでちょっと俺は首つか
できてるかなと思ってねあのその全然気に
入ってないよ全然気にしてないし買うと
借りるの全然違うし全然違うんですけども
お住まいになられたなとひしひしと思い
ますちょっとねそういうあの用語を越され
た20億それで当てるって思ったでしょ
[音楽]
焦りました
値段は違うけれどももう全然またちょっと
意味合いが違うのでもうねなんせもうお
めでとうございますの方が強いです本当に
行きたいコンシェルズとかいるのかな
召使いとか
賃貸でしょ管理してくれてるのかな結構俺
この家買ってすごい大変だなって思ったの
がまず管理なんですよ
草とか生えたりなんかあったり壊れたりし
たらすぐ直さなきゃいけないし自分でいや
親分
賢いな多分ね賃貸の方がね
楽というか
快適に過ごせるんだろうなっていうのは
大きいお家を買ってみて僕思ったポイント
なのでこれちょっとワンチャン親分俺の
この買ってしまった苦労の
経験を見て
選択されたような気も勝手にしてます
そんな本人にちょっとご連絡してみたいと
思いますもしもしお疲れ様です
お疲れ様です
20億円のおうちおめでとうございまーす
賃貸だけどねいや
賃貸ですけどやばいっす20億はもう買っ
てたらね
今ももういらっしゃるんですかそのうちに
持ってるよ今日たまたま今撮影でいるんだ
よ今いらっしゃるんですか
[拍手]
[音楽]
すごい
めっちゃ綺麗ですね
[音楽]
管理とかってしてもらえるんですか
賃貸で買われてたからなんか
草刈りとかしてたじゃないですか親分に
手伝ってもらったりしてたんですけど
なんかそれも見越して賃貸にしたのかなっ
ていう気がしました
[音楽]
けど
4億円の家がちっぽけに見えます
[音楽]
[笑い]
えマジで行きたいですいつか行かせて
ください
[音楽]
ダイナマイト持って言っていいですか言っ
てことはもう家賃を払ってるって事ですか
毎月
も結構あれですかひょっとしてあのその
あのー
あのねまあもちろんここもいい家賃すごい
してるんだけど
どっちかっていうとさ前のマンションを借
りっぱなんだよねあの
伝説の
ちょっとやばいなるほど
[音楽]
とかしないんだろうって言われてんだけど
結構
リアル破産の方なんですね
次はトレーニングルームだ動画で紹介され
てた場所ですね
すごいなぁ
管理できないですよね1個何か
さそこで
財布とかどこにあったっけってなるともう
1時間は消えると思ってください
[音楽]
まだもないからあーそっかそっかまだ
ちゃんと
銀色なんですかそれえすげー
[音楽]
めちゃくちゃ一箇所にしかない
電気代30万円って最近ソーラーパネル
つけてましたもうはい多分エアコンとか
だけでも相当やばいと思いますよもうビル
みたいな値段になると思うんで
旗をかけてやっていきますお互い頑張り
ましょうすみません忙しい中ありがとう
ございます
ありがとうございます
バイバイいやさすが親分すげー行きたい
行きたい行きたい
行きたい
はいHIKAKINさん20億だってやら
れた本当にやられた20億ですか
[音楽]
今だいたい1億使うのに2年か考えない
ちょっとカスタマイズしていきましょうあ
もっともう着々とねもちろんいきなり
そんなバンクアップとかできないと思うん
ですけどちょっと大地くんとねしっかり
話し合って値段が全てちゃうわけじゃない
ですけどもカスタム性でね見せていければ
いいねここは引き続きよろしくお願いし
ますはいというわけでHIKAKINさん
の20億円のお家に住んで思ったこと行き
たいこれにつきます行きたい泊まりたい
です
[音楽]
暴れたいですすごい
夢のある本当に素敵なニュースだと思い
ましたお家の相談たまに受けてたので
ようやく親分の新しいお家が見つかって
すごいあのYouTuber仲間として
いいなっていう感じですおめでとうござい
ます次のニュース次のニュースは
ヴァンゆんチャンネル
万有のバンビ君が日本人最速登録者数
1000万人を達成されたみたいです
ございます
えってなったよチャンネル名なんだっけ
スパイダーマンスパイダーマンという
万有のバンビ君がスパイダーメンっていう
仮面をかぶってスパイダーマンの自分の
素顔を出さずにスパイダーマンの格好して
主にショート動画かな縦の動画ショート
動画をバーって投稿しまくって日本人の
最速374日で登録者数を1000万人を
突破されたというニュースが出ておりまし
たおめでとうございます
いや普通にびっくりよびっくりだしやっぱ
1000万人と言ったらやっぱこことか
親分とかがこうやっぱイメージあるじゃ
ないですかいろいろこう聞かでるんですよ
聞かれたんですよバンビ君1000万人
突破についてどう思うかとかこれについて
とか
すごいしか出てこんすごいしか出てこない
これすごい以外の何事でもないですから
いやすごいよ顔隠してよ最速で1000万
人でしょめっちゃかっこいいすげえマジで
びっくりしたしユンちゃんがシルクと結婚
したとかなんか色々このわちゃわちゃして
たじゃないですかバンビ大丈夫かみたいな
それをズバッと跳ね除けるというかバンビ
君のかっこよさとかが詰まったニュースか
なと僕はあの見て思いましたこれもね多分
そのたくさん聞かれるっていう事は多分
比較してると思うんですよ僕と僕が
ヒカキンさんとかと比較というか多分気に
してるだろうなっていう読みでたくさん
聞かれたんだろうと思いますけども多分ね
バンビ君が達成したスパイダーメイン
チャンネルをあのショート動画で結構海外
向けのコンテンツが多くて
海外向けだと分母も視聴者のこの数も
すごい世界規模ですから1000万人
スパーンって最速で行けたと思うんです
けれどももうね
悔しいとかそういう感情じゃなくて
悔しいとかを思ってるんだろうなって思っ
てる人いるかもしれませんがあんまりない
ですねそういう感情はもうネットとかさ
すぐ人を比較したがるんだから
hikakinさんのお家とかもそう
でしょHIKAKINさん20億いきまし
た始め4どう思いましたとかバンビ君
1000万に最速突破はじめどう思いまし
たとかまあ数字が付いてる以上どうしても
比較されるかもしれませんけどもだったら
思ってること素直に話しますけどももうね
あの私もここまで来たら1000万人超え
てからもう僕あの一種の何でしょう
もちろん悔しいとかそういう感情でね
動画作り頑張れる人もいると思うんです
けれども俺はもう1000万人超えてから
もういかに自分のしたいことを突き詰め
られるかそんな感じで活動してるからね
もうなんかなこと言われてもっていう感じ
ではあります万引きに抜かれたからって別
に俺何か変わることもないし周りを気にし
ないように活動してるんですけどもそんな
皆さんがどう思いますかどう思いますか
言ったらもう答えちゃうからそんなに来る
んだったら答えるわっていう形今動画を
撮ってるわけなんですけれどももう俺はね
そんなこんなじゃもう動じないよ動じない
振る舞いをしておくよ俺はねもう自分のし
たいことを突き詰めてはじめしゃちょーと
してもう今後の初めて社長のことしか考え
てないのであまり周りは気にしないように
活動しております今夢中になってるのは
虫ヘラクレスですもう毎日700万円の
ヘラクレス飼育箱隠しシェルターに通って
ますもうそういう他のYouTuberが
どうとかもう今はそんな気にしてない
そんな暇があったら俺はヘラクレスに餌を
あげますゼリーあげます
霧吹きで水をかけて湿度を保ちます疲れる
んですよ人と比較されるのはとてもまた皆
さんが気になるようなことがあったら動画
にすると思いますけども
原則的にはもう
興味ないね焦りもない俺はただただ
ヘラクレスを愛でるだけそんな感じで
YouTube
活動してますバンビ君がねなんか言ってた
のが何て言ってたっけ今日本一の
YouTuberがtiktokerなん
ですってバンビ君曰くなんかいやいや日本
一はユーチューバーであって欲しいって
言ってましたけどもあの僕個人の意見です
よ私としましては誰でもいいですマジで誰
でもいい1位はそれも1位になれたら
かっこいいですけども一応誰でもいいです
人によってYouTube活動してる理由
は様々だと思うんですけれども俺もさすが
に1000万人行く時は1000万という
数字にこだわった時期もあったけど基本的
にこだわりがない時はもう自分のしたい
ことをいかに動画にできるかほんでそれで
いろんな人に見てもらえたら嬉しいなって
いう感覚で動画をやっておりますなので
競争心の欠片もないって言ったら嘘になっ
ちゃうんですけどそんな誰かを抜きたいと
か誰かに抜かれたとかこれはどう思うこれ
は悔しくないのかとかそういう感じはもう
ない他の人を気にしてる時間があったら
もっと自分のことだったり動画のことだっ
たりヘラクレスのことだったりヘラクレス
のことだったり考えたいと思ってます
なんかすごい関連性のある人物として
いろいろどう思ってるって聞かれたわけな
んですけれどもとても素敵なことだと思う
ので
素敵は素敵でいいんじゃないかと思います
はいというわけで自在ニュースヒカキン
さん20億円のおうちバンビ君1000万
人最速突破このニュースを聞いて僕が思っ
たことはヘラクレスに餌をあげたい
[音楽]